well population control is naturally
occurring I mean in Europe and Japan as
populations of live longer they have
dramatically reduced the birthrate so in
fact there's a shrinkage in both Europe
and Japan not in the United States
because of immigration but I think it
sort of balances itself out as people
live longer they tend to have fewer
babies and as a result they're able to
put more resources into the education
and the health of the children so it's
been a very positive thing if you think
back to 1900 when the average life
expectancy was 47 and you were asking me
this question you could have been
thinking where we're going to have all
those 50 year olds and now we have all
those 50 year olds so what I think we'll
see is a healthier more vigorous
population of people in their 70s and
80s then we've had before it's a result
of medical science and hopefully people
taking better care of themselves
you